foreign
this Saturday night a warm welcome
inside a war zone
prime minister Trudeau touches down in
another top secret visit as Ukraine's
counter-offensive begins it is important
for me to be here in person to show
Canada's solidarity with ukrainians
Canada's new commitment to Kiev in the
wake of that devastating Dam collapse
also tonight ordered out again Soviet we
unpacked because we weren't sure and
most of it was still packed another
round of extreme fire conditions in
Alberta forces evacuees to flee after
only just returning home plus holding
the reins in Alberta healthcare workers
should be very nervous in this in this
province the conservative Balancing Act
and what the province's new cabinet says
about the road ahead and Miracle
discovery
children found alive after 40
.
global national with bar Nasser
[Applause]
a resounding reception in Ukraine's
Parliament today as prime minister
Justin Trudeau and Deputy Prime Minister
Christian Freeland made a surprise visit
to the wartime Nation touching down for
top level talks with president velodimir
zielinski
Canada will continue to stand with
Ukraine with whatever it takes as long
as it takes
good evening and thank you for joining
us Justin Trudeau is in Kiev his second
top secret visit to Ukraine since
Russia's Invasion standing beside the
Prime Minister President zielinski
unveiled Ukraine's long-awaited
counter-offensive has finally begun
the country needs all the support it can
get right now and today Trudeau
announced another 500 million dollars in
Aid and weapons he also announced more
economic sanctions against individuals
and entities and 10 million dollars in
humanitarian Aid after that Dam collapse
and major flooding in the South this
week
this was a direct consequence of
Russia's war and it is devastating for
thousands upon thousands of people
crystal gemancing is in Kiev and has our
top story tonight
Ukraine's pain and persistence witnessed
firsthand by the Prime Minister and his
Deputy the faces of Fallen Soldiers a
reminder of the lives lost and those
still on the line
500 million dollars in new funding was
announced by Justin Trudeau to support
Ukraine as it repels invading Russian
forces more ammunition will also be
delivered
the list of new pledges also includes
Canada joining the Coalition of
countries to train Ukrainian fighter
pilots and it will help service Leopard
2 tanks at a center in Poland I
appreciate your own support thank you so
much people of Canada and of course to
all the European to the government the
Ukrainian president's comments come as
people in his country defend their
sovereignty while simultaneously
scrambling to recover from an
environmental and humanitarian disaster
the collapse of the novakahofka dam has
submerged housing villages in southern
Ukraine forced thousands to be rescued
and left many in the region with a short
supply of drinking water Mr Prime
Minister was it Russia that blew up the
Kahoka Dam after not answering our
question and then coaching his answer to
Ukrainian media the Prime Minister put a
finer point on the matter concluding his
response this way this
was a direct consequence of Russia's War
since Russia launched its full invasion
of its neighbor Ukraine has been
rallying the world for support saying
it's defending democracy for all NATO
meanwhile has been trying to reassure
member states on the doorstep of the
largest war on European soil since the
second world war Canada still hasn't met
the NATO member Target of two percent
GDP for defense spending so really what
example is Canada setting on the world
stage Canada is the sixth larger uh is
sixth largest in NATO by defense
spending and we have consistently
stepped up and will continue to all over
the world being equipped and able to
protect Canadians or any NATO member is
a requirement Ukraine has aspirations of
joining but knows it can't while the war
is ongoing Canada supports its
membership and says it will keep
providing the country and its people
with anything at its disposal for the
long term no bombs no bullets and no
bullies will ever take away your drive
for freedom and your pride in your
culture your language your history and
your future as ukrainians
clearly the Prime Minister gave
Ukrainian parliamentarians a morale
boost and it comes just as their country
launches its counter-offensive Vladimir
zielinski wouldn't say what phase they
are in only that he was sure the
Russians would feel it
Farah
Crystal command saying in key for us
thank you so much Crystal for that
a giant Russian cargo plane that's been
sitting on the tarmac at Toronto Pearson
Airport for more than a year has
officially been seized by the Canadian
government the aircraft is believed to
be a subsidiary of two entities against
which Canada recently imposed sanctions
due to their part in the war against
Ukraine the plane was scheduled to leave
Toronto shortly after arriving in
February of 2022 but Canada closed its
airspace to Russian aircraft operators
grounding it indefinitely
all right now to the Wildfire situation
it is still a tense wait for residents
of Tumbler Ridge British Columbia the
fire is just kilometers away from the
community but as residents head into a
fourth day out of their homes there is
some good news from officials today
Romina Daya is on the front lines and
she joins us now with more Romina
pharah yesterday was a heavy day for
Tumblr Ridge evacuees who thought their
town was going to be gone for sure but
it's still standing
an army of firefighters and volunteers
from across the province are in Tumblr
Ridge Crews have been spraying down
homes and infrastructure to protect the
buildings in case the fire starts moving
aggressively again more Sprinklers and
more resources are on Route the crews
hoping their presence will give evacuees
some peace of mind we're doing the best
we can trying to get as prepared as we
can for for what might come this way
with the fire so close we're we're
hoping that we'll be able to do
everything we can to to save their
community and even if it's just
reassurance over you know talking to you
that homes are okay and we're doing our
best to protect them can't guarantee
outcomes but we're here doing our best
to
to do what we can to save it
2 400 residents were ordered to leave
their homes Thursday when the fire
exploded The Blaze currently about four
kilometers away from town while it looks
like a normal day today it's dangerously
deceiving the sprinkle of rain not
enough to make a dent the risk is still
very high you know that doesn't change
the fuel content or the moisture in the
ground so
feels good but we're not there yet
fire crews are taking advantage of the
weather right now laying fire breaks but
this isn't going to last it's a fluid
situation the wild card is the wind
pharah
Romina Daya near Tumbler Ridge British
Columbia thanks Romina
and for the second time in a month
residents of Edson Alberta about two
hours west of Edmonton have been told to
leave their homes because of an
encroaching wildfire
we left at midnight so the fire was
about three kilometers from our place
and we can actually see the orange glow
and the Flames so it was pretty
stressful
an emergency alert was issued for the
town of 8 000 people last night after
the fire jumped and showed unpredictable
Behavior there are at least four out of
control fires burning around Edson
and in Quebec more than 850 firefighters
are now on the ground battling dozens of
wildfires another 300 firefighters from
the United States Portugal and Spain are
expected early next week and in the
northern and western part of the
province more than 13 thousand people
are still out of their homes the
province's public safety Minister says
the situation is complicated but key
areas could see Rain by Tuesday
to the political Fallout in Ottawa after
David Johnston's bombshell announcement
Friday the former Governor General
resigned as the special repertoire
investigating foreign interference in
our elections now this was after
criticism for his ties to the Prime
Minister and growing demands for a
public inquiry on interference but its
departure hasn't brought the issue any
closer to a solution Richard zusman
reports
a Friday night surprise after weeks of
political and public Pressure David
Johnston stepping down as the special
rapporteur investigating foreign
interference in Canadian elections
Johnson writing in his resignation
letter to the Prime Minister when I
undertook the task of independent
special rapporteur on foreign
interference my objective was to help
build trust in our Democratic
institutions I have concluded that given
the highly partisan atmosphere around my
appointment and work my leadership has
had the opposite effect we had tasked
David Johnston to do the report that he
did and make recommendations he did
excellent work now we're looking at the
next steps this Repertory process needed
to end and we need to have an open
public transparent inquiry in his
initial report Johnston concluded a full
public inquiry was not a suitable option
but the federal government says it's now
considering all options and challenging
the opposition make suggestions about
who could lead this public inquiry what
would the terms of reference be what do
they see as the timelines how do they
deal with the obvious challenge of
respecting Canadian law that protects
some of the most sensitive intelligence
information Trudeau has asked Dominic
LeBlanc to figure out next steps by
Consulting with experts and legal
Scholars some who are already suggesting
an inquiry we need to actually be very
careful with their expectations right
four of interference is some of the most
close hold intelligence that the
government actually has and we've seen
that in the various leaks that have come
out Johnston's work was overshadowed by
opposition concerns about his
relationship with the Prime Minister and
his family now that he's gone experts
say it's time for politicians to work
together these people have it within
them to do it they need to resist their
worst instincts and get on with the job
to which they are elected and now for
all parties want some input in terms of
who's going to be in charge next the
federal government says it's crucial to
do it right the second time to ensure
there's trust from the public in our
institutions pharah
thank you Richard that's Richard zusman
reporting from Victoria
and for the West block this week our
Ottawa birchief Mercedes Stevenson also
sat down with intergovernmental affairs
minister Dominic LeBlanc as Richard
mentioned he's now tasked with helping
the government figure out another
approach to addressing foreign
interference and here is part of that
conversation
so that consultation would be for a
special rapporture or for someone to
lead an inquiry somebody to lead a
public process we've always inquiry or
public process again but and that's
that's a good question so let's see if
the opposition parties come forward with
serious suggestions around how an
inquiry could be set up but why is that
their job you're you're the government
that's kind of like me saying my viewers
should write my questions and send them
to me so if you want me to ask those
tough questions you need to give them to
me aren't you the government isn't it
your job to figure out how to do this
they all voted together last week
Mercedes to say that the opposition
leaders should suggest somebody to lead
this inquiry that was the NDP motion
they all voted for last week so tell us
who it is tell us what the terms of
reference would be I mean we believe
there should be a public process going
forward as Mr Johnston recommended we're
prepared to consider all options the
Prime Minister said that some months ago
we'll say that again but they've got to
do more than simply demand a public and
inquiry we're not going to set up
something they don't though they're the
opposition and you're the government
it's up to you to set up the processes
here right and you could have called the
public inquiry from day one but we asked
Mr Johnson to evaluate all of these
circumstances which he did in a
thoughtful way they decided to attack
him on a partisan basis we think that
was disgraceful
um we're not going to get somebody
credible to come forward uh we and you
can see that entire conversation
tomorrow on the west block right here on
global
shaping Alberta's future coming up
Premier Danielle Smith's new cabinet and
the key position signaling a power shift
to the right
after triumving in the Alberta election
Premier Danielle Smith's new government
will take the summer to develop policy
before returning to the legislature this
fall and if the makeup of her new
cabinet is any indication that policy
could be fueled by more right-wing
ideology than anything the province has
seen before Heather York's West reports
hi Brian June do solemnly and sincerely
promised it is the First Act of
Alberta's newly elected United
conservative government and the faces
chosen to form Danielle Smith's next
cabinet began to tell a story about the
plant wrote ahead what struck me the
most is the strong uh experienced voices
that she's tapped to be in her cabinet
just signals to me that she's after
experience and stability welcome to
another miracle on the prairies
the UCP may have won another majority
government but many former cabinet
ministers in Alberta's two big cities
lost their seats Calgary and Edmonton
are still represented in the new 25-seat
cabinet with nine seats going to Calgary
mlas and three to representatives from
the so-called Edmonton donut bedroom
municipalities like Sherwood Park and
Spruce Grove far from having gender
parity there are just five women in the
new cabinet including Premier Smith with
Brian Jean and Rebecca Schultz heading
up the two roles that the federal
government will need to work with
closely as it pursues climate
initiatives Gene a former leader of the
further right-leaning Wild Rose party
from Fort McMurray becomes the new
energy Minister while Rebecca Schultz a
more moderate conservative takes on
environment hi Adriana LaGrange do
solemnly Health Care will be handled by
Red Deer MLA Adriana LaGrange I think
there's certainly further right elements
I mean putting LaGrange into health is
is absolutely terrifying uh if she
brings her ideological uh bent to health
the way she did to education I think
that healthcare workers should be very
nervous in this in this province
lagrange's work with pro-life Alberta
prompted Smith to make a public promise
Friday that Alberta's abortion rules
would remain unchanged limiting future
tax hikes will be Priority One but Smith
says Health Care reforms and energy
industry protections will follow I have
a very ambitious agenda and we have a
lot of work to do for albertans the new
Alberta government in place to get that
work done Heather urich's West Global
News Calgary
[Music]
I had counter-offensive challenges after
the break I speak with a Russian foreign
policy expert about Russia's ongoing
aggression but also the blame game over
that damn blast and the end game
[Music]
returning to the war in Ukraine now
prime minister Justin Trudeau's surprise
visit to Kiev today an announcement of
new support comes at a crucial time in
the conflict
after rapid Russian gains at the onset
of the war Ukrainian forces made steady
progress regaining territory but since
the start of this year that progress has
slowed and Russian forces are entrenched
along much of eastern Ukraine and Crimea
joining us now with Suzanne Loftus
research fellow at the Quincy
institute's Eurasia program Suzanne
thanks for being with us we're now over
15 months into this conflict and of
course some thought that Russia might
claim a quick Victory but Ukraine has
had supportive countries like Canada and
the U.S how important has that been and
how much is Ukraine relying on that
assistance to continue
Ukraine is heavily relying on that
assistance right now in its efforts at
defending itself against Russian
aggression it has been the most
important source of support from NATO
countries and it has enabled and allowed
Ukraine to properly defend itself
without that support the Russians would
have been able to advance much further
than they already have and this includes
not just Military Support but also
humanitarian support but at the same
time while the support is very important
we need to strategize about how long
it's going to last and how long we're
going to be financing what's going on in
Ukraine right now we need to kind of
come up with an end game
and that's I think what a lot of people
are wondering about speaking of support
though there was a major event in the
conflict this week the destruction of a
dam on the nepro river do we know who
destroyed it and why
we still don't know who the perpetrator
was it would be improbable that it would
be the Russians actually because this
hurts them a lot as well it floods all
of their the Russian controlled parts of
there's agriculture that's flooding but
also it's preventing the supply of water
to Crimea and this is a very important
uh you know this is very important in
general for the Russians so it would
seem a little odd that they would do
that to themselves so at this point we
don't know who did it it's possible that
it could have been unintentional and
that it just got destroyed over time due
to limited strikes that are caused and
weaknesses
how is the destruction of the dam
impacted Ukraine's counter-offensive
yeah so right now because of all the
flooding ukrainians are not conducting
the any large-scale activities in that
region but that would just be temporary
they could do so later when the Waters
of sides at this moment the main
counter-offensive movement and activity
has been seen mostly in Donetsk we've
also seen summons operations
but this is also not quite the major
units are not quite sent yet this is
more of a preliminary phase to kind of
test the Russian vulnerabilities and uh
so we're yet to see a major activity
you know you touched on this a bit
earlier but both sides appear entrenched
are there any options for an exit from
this conflict
well at this moment both sides are
extremely far away from one another in
the sense that there doesn't seem to be
any type of Middle Ground possible
between the two and at the same time
there's also what appears to be somewhat
of a stalemated situation on the ground
where both sides are making very small
gains or small losses Suzanne Loftus
from the Quincy institute's Eurasia
program thanks so much for being with us
thank you for having me
[Music]
next missing for 40 days and feared lost
forever the remarkable Rescue of four
young children from the Colombian jungle
[Music]
a powerful moment in Colombia more than
a month after a small plane crash four
young siblings had been rescued from the
rainforest it may be home to Jaguars and
rattlesnakes but it's the small
footprints that Searchers found that
gave them hope the children were still
alive
oh
in an instant weeks of fear and
uncertainty turn to Joy and relief for
the grandparents of four children as
they learned the siblings are alive the
children 13 9 4 and an out 12 month old
baby were found in the inhospitable
Colombian jungle not far from where the
small plane they were on crashed 40 days
ago
their grandfather telling reporters he's
delighted at the remarkable turn of
events the Cessna 206 was carrying seven
people when it issued a Mayday alert due
to engine failure on May 1st three
adults including the pilot and the
children's mother died in the crash the
search within the dense jungle was
dubbed Operation Hope and one point
Rescuers found discarded fruits the
children ate to survive as well as
improvised shelters but no sign of them
then last night when they were found the
Colombian military shared this photo
with Soldiers the siblings were
airlifted to Bogota where they're
receiving Medical Care and a visit from
the Colombian president the next stop
home to be reunited with their family
after five very long weeks
incredible and that's global national
for this Saturday night I'm Farah Nasser
tonight's your Canada is Jasper Alberta
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and take care of each other good night